news alert this
has supposedly been used to help stalk
unsuspecting people since last year
apple recently issued a notice about it
acknowledging that air tags were being
used for nefarious purposes but how do
you know it's happening how do you know
if someone's trying to stalk you
i'm gonna show you by attempting to
stalk myself
for those who don't know air tags don't
use gps they let iphones and other
devices let people know that they're
nearby using low power bluetooth
when you're close to an air tag your
ipod ipad or iphone can silently
transmit that location to the cloud this
is meant to help people find their lost
belongings but this also happens when an
air tag is intentionally placed on
someone to set it up you just hold your
iphone near the air tag and then you use
apple's find my app to keep track of it
now there are already some anti-stalking
features baked into my phone that are
supposed to tell me or you if an air tag
is separated from its owner and lurking
or moving with you
last year apple started notifying people
if an unknown air tag showed up with
them at home according to some police
reports it's how some people detected
that an unknown accessory was planted on
them
i was being informed that there has been
an air tag that has been following me
since five o'clock
they've been tracking me play the noise
let's start there okay
do you hear that and apple says it's
working on a way to try to show you that
alert sooner but how long does it take
for apple to let me know that an air tag
might be stalking me
uh could it be too late i'm going to put
that to the test
first i need a couple things two iphones
logged into two separate icloud accounts
and an air tag
then i'm linking this brand new air tag
to my producer's iphone that way apple
doesn't think it's my air tag traveling
with me let's go
so i'm headed to a local coffee shop to
activate the air tag again it's linked
to my producer's icloud account not mine
i'm gonna have you have a green tea
once this air tag is registered all a
creeper would need to do is slip it into
my bag
and wait
now i'm going to leave this iphone
linked to my producer's icloud account
in the car and see how long it takes for
apple to tell me that the air tag is
tracking me
so this is what it looks like being
stocked the app will show you the
airtag's approximate location when it's
within range of another apple device in
this case it's probably being beamed to
the cloud through my personal iphone and
my producer is tracking its whereabouts
on apple's find my app in the meantime i
might even hear a little beep coming
from the air tag it's really useful if
you're trying to find your lost keys and
even more useful if you're trying to
avoid being unwittingly tracked apple
says it's working on making the beep
louder
so here's what happened i went about my
day running errands with my producer's
air tag still in my backpack
i
waited
checked my phone settings and continued
to wait
but nothing it was pure silence that is
until i fell asleep at about 1 30 in the
morning the air tag woke me up with a
loud chime
and even though it was in another room
and at the bottom of my backpack i could
still hear it and it was loud enough to
wake me up i scrambled to capture the
whole thing on camera but the alert
didn't last long enough during more than
two days of testing my iphone never made
a sound so i contacted apple to let them
know what i found the company says in a
perfect world you should hear an air tag
make a chime somewhere between 8 and 24
hours after it's been separated from its
owner and you should get an alert on
your iphone when the find my network
realizes you made it home apple's
precision finding for iphones released
after 2018 will lead you directly to
your own air tags you can't use that to
find rogue air tags yet but apple says
it's working on a way to implement that
in the future while the unknown air tag
alert didn't work for me this is all
sort of still good news for iphone users
yes people can plan air tags on you to
try to stalk you but your iphone has the
tools to help without you having to do
anything at all that's assuming those
tools work before it's too late apple
says stalking incidents are rare but if
someone is trying to track you their
airtag is linked to their icloud account
so take the device to your authorities
and apple will try to work with them to
identify the person behind it
all of apple's anti-stalking features
are free passive and turned on by
default that might give you more
security than other bluetooth trackers
like this tile which has little if any
anti-stalking features the company
behind tile though says it's working on
making more of those and for android
users apple created an app called
tracker detect it won't automatically
look for rogue air tags you have to
manually search for them in my case
tracker detect told me that an unknown
air tag was in my vicinity within an
hour of me making it home it allowed me
to activate an alarm to locate my
producer's air tag but i am still
waiting for that iphone alert
it took two more stalking attempts with
a brand new air tag before i actually
got an iphone alert but the notification
was pretty telling it showed me roughly
how far the air tag moved with me as
well as where i was when a friend
planted it on me
if you want to know more about the
latest tech how things work and where
it's all headed be sure to subscribe and
comment below to let me know what topics
i should examine next we will chat soon
[Music]
you